sometimes you sort of just have to jump
off the deep end and then find your feet
once you're out there you're never going
to feel already my first race
back was terrible it was absolutely
terrible and I was so afraid to do it as
well like was I Delirious in thinking
that this was impossible for me but you
know it's just it's just going to be too
hard and and I think I did develop it
slowly I think over a couple years like
building up the confidence to to make
the changes and sacrifices I made to get
back in the pool or to change change my
lifestyle
failure isn't failure really failure or
just it's information it's information
yeah exactly it's information it's it's
um you know a bad race or a bad session
or something is just as important as a
good one and I think just developing the
capacity for resilience I think is
important but the only way you can do
that is by putting yourself in
uncomfortable situations or forcing
yourself to do things that you just
don't think you can do